[Music]
[Applause]
the next Studio host and a contributor
to Around the Horn pardon the
interruption and uh Sirius XM NBA Radio
this starting lineup Frank the greatest
unanswered Sports question in history is
ask ask your folks because before you
came on they asked me and that was the
one I came up with also I said Michael
Jordan leaving for those two years what
exactly was the reason and does Chicago
and you and I were around during that
run I believe they absolutely win those
two championships and maybe Michael
Jordan would have won eight in a row and
one other thing about you guys both
mentioned I had to laugh about the
Frozen envelope that might have been put
in uh dry ice the whole thing I remember
doing a story when I was at the Daily
News because the Knicks were back in the
lottery for the first time in a long
time and I got David Stern on the phone
and I asked him two questions about the
Frozen envelope and on the second one he
said I think we should move on Frank
before you keep continuing to accuse me
of a felony you know David Stern had
that way about him I said yes sir and I
moved on to something else um
do you think there will ever be a 30 for
30 on Michael Jordan and why he really
went to play baseball or do you think
there's going to be an expose on that
that he really went to play baseball
because he was burned out with
basketball and he wanted to do this
because his dad always wanted him to try
to play baseball yeah and I always think
with these things it's never just one
thing it's even when guys step away from
coaching or from playing I think his dad
uh passing away probably had something
to do with maybe he really was worn down
maybe he was in trouble with the league
over something it is funny during the um
the great the Last Dance
they did address it a bit and they just
you know the rumor out there that maybe
he was going to get in trouble for
gambling and instead of being suspended
he said you know what I'm just going to
walk away for a while and they asked
four people about it it was a Brian
McIntyre who was David Stern's right
hand man David Falk Michael Jordan and I
believe David Stern was estimated too I
think those would be the only four
people in the world that would know the
real story and all four of them said
you're crazy if you think he just
decided to walk away the Iowa always was
convinced those were the only four
people that know the true story what do
you think happened
I think he was a little worn down I
think you know being Michael Jordan
probably got to him a little bit maybe
he wanted another child you know he had
been spoken to about some of his ties to
you know who was the gamble that he
played golf with and maybe he said you
know what I'm getting tired of any
questions about this stuff you guys see
how the leak survives without me for a
year and maybe again I think it might
have been a number of factors
last night at the ESPYs it's the
greatest night in sports because you
work at ESPN and yes you're supposed to
uh love the ESPYs here is a portion of
LeBron James speech
LeBron James speech everything to the
game still
truth is I've been asking myself this
question at the end of the season for
a couple years now
I just never openly talked about it
I don't care how many more points I
score or what I can and cannot do on the
floor
the real question for me is can I play
without cheating this game
the day I can't give the game everything
on the floor
it's the day I'll be done
lucky for you guys that day is not today
okay why is this a celebration who
thought LeBron was going to retire
nobody did okay but he gave us a story
for like a day and in the moments right
after you lose a playoff game guys
saving that a week two weeks a month
later don't really hold true and let's
remember something as well all there was
was talk about him playing eventually
one day with his son his son is going to
be at USC this year if he stays one year
then LeBron will have a chance to play
with him two years down the road after
talking about playing with his son all
this time you get eliminated by Denver
and he decides in that moment I'm done
no one ever believed that no one
believed that for a moment the thing too
is though when he said cheating the game
I think the players today so they look
at a little bit different I think LeBron
knows at his age and the way that he
plays and to stay healthy he could
probably give you 60 solid games during
the regular season someone's got to take
care about the other 20 to 22 and then
I'll see you in the playoffs that's the
issue now how can the Lakers survive
without LeBron because you figure the
days of him playing 70 games I think are
over it's probably more in the 60 range
right now but I'm also wondering this
does LeBron stay if he is not the number
one option or I mean Anthony Davis
should be the number one option but he
has you know failed in doing that yeah I
think he I think he wants Anthony Davis
to be the number one option that's kind
of part of the problem you watch the way
the guy played during the playoffs I'm
talking about LeBron he was still a
dominant Force you know it's amazing on
the one hand that at his age he could
still do this but I think there's part
of him that says come on guys somebody
else needs to do this let me be part of
it every once in a while I'll have a
great game because even when they were
winning some of those playoff games it
wasn't like LeBron was giving you the 38
Point triple double he was still playing
well enough he still makes those around
him better but he still needs a little
bit of help here at this age yeah but I
wonder could he be a second or third
option like would his ego allow that to
happen because he's become a jump
shooter you know he doesn't want the
wear and tear going to the hoop anymore
it's he's settling for jumpers and he's
not a good jump shooter but I wonder
you know Anthony Davis could be the
first option they're not going to have a
second option but I wonder if he could
get into that role of like Chris Bosh
did in Miami exactly where he became a
third option for the betterment of the
team you know if if he went to let's say
for argument's sake he went to a place
like Denver
I think he he would certainly work in an
ensemble cast there with Jamal Murray
and Nicole jokic maybe it'd be the
second option if he ever made it to the
Golden State Warriors I think at this
stage he would and he certainly would if
that team had gets his son bronnie and
then LeBron wants to play there if
LeBron went to a team at already that
dominant number one guy do you really
think he's going to play on a team with
his son I think you know you hear Brian
one horse talk about it all the time I
think LeBron still wants to win a title
but I think the thing that makes it
would make it unique for him is to play
with his son because remember
he's probably not going to get the six
titles that Michael had but he's got the
all-time scoring record
and now he could do something that
Michael never got to do you're going to
play with his son professionally you
know we still talk about when Ken
Griffey Senior played with Ken Griffey
Jr how incredible that was for LeBron to
be able to do that to have that kind of
staying power but part of it too is
that's LeBron's dream what is his son's
dream I know this Dan is Santa's gonna
make about four to five six million
dollars in nil at USC yeah it's kind of
a nice life being on the USC campus this
son might look around and say you know
what this might be better than just
being at the end of somebody's bench in
the NBA maybe I'll Stick Around USC for
a while how do you think this plays out
with Miami and Portland with Dame I
think it eventually will happen I love
the fact that Joe Cronin has to come out
and remind everyone we get it Pat
Riley's great he's The Godfather the
Miami Heat fans are all crazy they think
Damian Lulu should have been traded
there a week ago and you have the people
in the media and NBA players think that
Damian Lillard should get just get
whatever he wants well Joe Cronin his
best interest is the Portland
Trailblazer and guess what he's allowed
to want to do what's best for Portland
and get a good deal for them no one
knows Joe Cronin so the first move that
he's ever really going to make that
people are paying attention to is
trading one of the most popular players
if not the most popular player in
franchise history is he allowed to get a
good deal back for him or is it just
about making Damian Lillard happy the
Miami Heat fan base happy and Pat Riley
happy like it'll happen at some point
but it's complicated Dan it's probably
going to include multiple teams when you
do that these trades uh tend to take a
while I know you spent time at the
summer league and I always like to see
what competition you're facing so Victor
one by Amma I think we were looking at
him we weren't necessarily looking at
the competition it was just him he was
sort of the only guy out there even
though there were nine other players on
the floor the biggest question that you
still have about Victor one by Amma is
what well I would think physically can
he hold up because Chet Holger who has
been dominant in summer league it's the
second year in the league he missed all
of last season he got hurt playing that
Pro-Am out in Seattle so that to me
would be the big thing you know
physically Kenny hold up well enough
because I that the first game that he
played you know he he was not good
offensively why people just couldn't say
that it doesn't mean that he's not going
to be a good player doesn't mean that
he's a boss but I just find it weird
that he everyone was trying we there's a
million excuses why he didn't play that
well he's 19 he just finished a season
in the French league all the attention
the pressure maybe the Britney Spears
thing had something to do with the sold
out crowd but let's acknowledge that he
didn't have a good game offensively
defensively he was pretty good and then
he had a good bounce back game on Sunday
and then they decided to shut him down I
know this Greg popitz who usually during
summer league is hanging out I think
he's got a house up in Maine he was
there for both the victim and benihama's
game so clearly it means something to
Greg Popovich enough so that he got a
five-year contract extension as well
if they got scoot Henderson and not
Victor won by ammo
is Greg Popovich signing a five-year
contract I don't think he is I don't
think he is and that's why and you know
this when you look at the teams that
were going to be in the lottery I kept
thinking he's either going to go to
Orlando who always seems to get a center
Shack and Dwight Howard or the Rockets
if you know Ralph Sampson Hakeem Yao
Ming or he's going to go to San Antonio
the team that always gets lucky David
Robinson Tim Duncan sure enough it ends
up being the San Antonio Spurs I think
you're right I think that Greg Papa just
looks at it as a challenge remember how
many people had said Greg Popovich will
leave when Tim Duncan leaves Tim
Duncan's been out of the league a long
time and Greg Popovich still is just
signed a five-year deal so he's not
giving up anytime soon good to talk to
you Frank thanks for joining us as
always good seeing you Dan take care
Frank Isola net Studio host and
contributor to around the horn and
pardon the interruption